Speaker 1: I have no choice but to start today
with the brazen and immoral not just willingness
but desire to hurt Americans from the newly
in control of the House of Representatives
Republican Party because they believe it will help
them in 2024. Yesterday, I told you about a post
that the failed former President Donald Trump made
to his social media platform, Truth, Social truth
Central. And to review that post. Let's just put
it up on the screen where Donald Trump said in
all capital letters, quote, Republicans can get
almost everything back that the old broken crow
Mitch McConnell and the real leader, China centric
Coco Chao, stupidly gave up to the Democrats over
the last two years by simply playing tough in the
upcoming debt ceiling negotiations with the right
negotiators. Like all of those involved the other
night on both sides for speaker. It will be a
beautiful and joyous thing for the people of our
country to watch Make America Great Again. Now,
you sometimes have to read between the lines when
Trump speaks because it's not even clear he knows
what he's saying in this case. He does know
what he's saying. He is saying shut down the
government over the debt ceiling, damage the
country, which will then show people how much
they want Republicans in power and they will vote
for us in 2024. Now, it was not just Donald Trump
who became willing to say this over the last 24
hours. We have countless more examples now, and
I'm going to look at a couple. First and foremost,
last night, Sean HANNITY, Fox News propagandist,
hosted some kind of a sort of town hall type
event with the new speaker of the House, Kevin
McCarthy. And here is Sean HANNITY suggesting
to Kevin McCarthy, shut down the government,
shut down the government when it comes down
to the debt ceiling debate. Take a listen.
Speaker 2: To, by the way, what they did
in the Senate. I believe as a conservative,
that was a disgrace. Yeah, I think. And they
knew you were coming into power and they knew
they could. Why wouldn't they? Why wait?
Speaker 3: If they waited, then we'd have
a stronger hand. We wouldn't be increasing
it. And they increase the baseline where
it just adds so much more to our children.
Speaker 2: Let's talk about a moment. Maybe
it comes sooner or maybe it comes later
on the debt ceiling. And you know how
the argument will unfold. It'll be Republicans
are shutting down government. I've been around
this game too long. Government never shuts
down. Essential services will exist. Grandma,
mom and dad, they're going to get their Social
Security check. Medicare is not going to be shut
down. The military is not going to be shut down.
Now, there might be people that get furloughed
are. But odds are pretty high that when they get
their free vacation, that they will get back pay.
But that will be the argument.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So HANNITY likes
the idea here of the government shutdown.
Speaker 2: Now, the question will be it'll
become a game of chicken. And that
is Republicans are shutting down
the government and they're not willing to raise
the debt ceiling. And you're going to say what?
Speaker 3: Well, listen, it doesn't
have to come to that. I've already
spoken to the president. Let's sit down now.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So HANNITY likes the idea and
he says they'll say it's bad for the country when
the government when the government is shut down,
but it's not really that bad for the country. Now,
I disagree with that, and I'm going to explain
that to you in a moment. Here is another
example, new Republican Congresswoman Ana
Paulina Luna. She says she's also willing
to support a shutdown of the government.
Speaker 4: I just stand by because
it's going to be a wild week.
Speaker 5: Well, you know, some of your more
moderate members within the Republican Party,
as I'm sure you know, say that's a dangerous
thing because it sets up almost a guaranteed
government shutdown and that because spending
has been tied to renegotiate the debt limit
or extending it. It's inevitable. Do
you think it's inevitable that we'll
be looking at a shutdown because of some of
these measures that the speaker agreed to?
Speaker 4: I hope it doesn't get to that, but
I'm willing to support one. And I do think that
the speaker made the correct decision
in ensuring that we do cut again some
of this pork, runaway inflation and spending.
Speaker 1: And so she's willing to support a
government shutdown. Now, of course, there's two
sides to this. The first side of it is that for
many of these Republicans, the government
being shut down is a feature, not a bug,
in the sense that, as I've told you many
times before, many of these right wingers want
government doing as little as possible. And so for
them, when they say, oh, the government shutdown,
that's great, as much as we can take off of
the list of things that government is doing,
that's a good thing. Now, often they can't
come out and publicly say that, but privately,
many of them love government shutdown because they
don't want the government doing stuff. They still
want their paychecks, by the way, but they don't
want government doing stuff. But it is not true
that when the government is shutdown over the
debt ceiling, it doesn't impact anything. Now,
in a sense, yes, in the immediate people
continue. To get Social Security checks.
But when the government shuts down, essential
government services stop being funded. That
does include Social Security and Medicare. Now,
in the immediate, people still get their checks,
but it is not indefinitely true. And so the idea
that it has no impact is, of course, a lie. It
can also lead to a slowdown in the economy. When
the government shuts down government contracts,
government purchases are put on hold. Government
employees are furloughed. Sometimes they get back
pay, sometimes they don't. It can cause job losses
and financial difficulties for the government
workers, but also for the private sector
businesses that rely on government spending. Now,
again, some of these Republicans love that. Some
of these Republicans think we, the government,
shouldn't do deals with private businesses. The
government shouldn't be spending, the government
shouldn't be doing. The government should be shut
down. That's their default. That's very extreme.
We're talking about those in the middle who say,
well, I want the government open in principle,
but it's not that bad. If it's shutdown,
it really can be very, very bad. It raises
the risk of a debt default, which can have more
than dire consequences. A default can lead to an
increase in interest rates, and that makes it more
expensive for the government to borrow money for
individuals and businesses to borrow money as a
result of that. All of these things, when they say
there's no negative impact, what I think they're
saying is if we contrive this deliberately,
but it only lasts a little while, we will reopen
after we've made our political point before things
get too bad. But that's an extraordinarily
cynical approach to how you do politics. And
the truth is that a government shutdown is bad
for the American people in all sorts of different
ways. It's irresponsible, it's reckless, and they
are willing to do it. They don't have principles,
or at least the principles they have are very
different than the ones they publicly state.
A real principle for the 2023 Republican
Party or House Republicans, we could say
is let's do whatever we think is best for us
politically over the next couple of years. That's
a real principle. The principles they'll state are
were for small government conservatism and freedom
and liberty and the Constitution and supporting
law enforcement and that matter. Every single
one of those we've seen abandoned when they're no
longer convenient. The real principle that they
pledge allegiance to in an unwavering fashion is
one they won't say out loud. We will do whatever
it takes to try to make Democrats look bad and
to try to help ourselves for our own reelections
and whatever the next election cycle is there.
They're making it very clear. They're saying it
openly. And by the way, they're also now talking
about diversity while in a room full of white
people emblematic of what the Republican
Party is. I want to talk about that next.
Did you know that half of Americans are deficient
in vitamin A, vitamin C and magnesium? Most
Americans are deficient in vitamin D. I take
vitamin D during the winter. It is sometimes
difficult to eat exactly the right amount of each
food to get exactly what you need. I just make
my life simpler with AG one by athletic greens
in the morning. One scoop of AG one. I get the
entire day's worth of 75 high quality vitamins,
minerals and whole foods sourced ingredients. It's
what I want. It's no more, it's no less. It's not
making any outlandish claims. It's just an easy,
sustainable routine. I've tried different ways of
taking vitamins. AG One is cheaper, it's quicker,
it's tastier. I'm not fumbling around with
different capsules. It tastes great to drink
straight with water. Sometimes I'll put it in a
smoothie or shake. It's simple. It's something
easy you can do. Going into the New Year, staying
properly nourished, athletic Greens is giving my
audience a three year supply of Vitamin D. I
take that every day in winter. Plus you'll get
five free travel packs of AG one go to athletic
green scum slash Pacman. The link is down below.